what i mean jc fernandez he's there at
fremont street experience what's up jc
hey hey michael nikki your rapping was
unbelievable we got bobby brown
happening right now and
vanilla ice coming up later on and i'm
looking at this crowd and people are
dressed up in 80s and 90s here i mean
[Applause]
how iconic is vanilla ice now i feel
kind of out of place in a tuxedo it's a
little bit too late to get the vanilla
ice jacket so what i figured i would do
why not go for the vanilla ice hair so i
made a call my stylist buffalo larry has
a shop downtown so i brought him
downtown
buffalo larry
gonna give me the vanilla ice haircut
live on television the three bars right
larry that's right take this off
do it right let me add let me actually
have a question
about yourself until you ring in 2022
guys whose fault is that yes
in there no just the streets just the
streets
where the streets have no name
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no it's great jesse you look great
it's great it's right now taking 22.92
off right
now could you ever rap were you ever
arrived
ah no no i was not i wasn't like uh wait
didn't it go up it goes
stop
[Music]
collaborate and listen is that how the
dance goes oh
yeah i think so it's just a haircut yes
oh no i like his things and i like your
dance jc
if you want rap tips i can give you a
few things no please don't
oh yeah exactly you guys here's the deal
though my wife went to bed early so i'm
gonna get home tonight get into bed and
she's gonna wake up and see this
tomorrow morning
we gotta go